foreign
that I must have given you so much
course to hate me so much to Target me
and my family to make threats against me
I'm sorry
[Music]
it's really hard to see
him struggling and that he's had to call
the racism and the disgusting filth that
has been put online and I'm so grateful
for everyone here today who's supporting
him and not just my dad but all other
First Nations
um journalists and I'm incredibly sorry
that he felt left down by our
organization I feel like I'm part of the
problem and I need to ask myself how or
if we can do it better I am down right
now I am but I'll get back up
and you can come at me again
and I'll meet you with the love of my
people